todos hemos tenido alguna herida en un
dedo o en cualquier otra parte de
nuestro cuerpo y de inmediato esa parte
del cuerpo se enrojece un poco se hincha
tal vez aumenta de temperatura y por
supuesto hay un cierto dolor asociado
con esa herida y en general a este
conjunto de síntomas que experimentamos
se les conoce como respuesta
inflamatoria o podríamos decir que hay
una inflamación por aquí y las personas
saben de esto desde siempre porque todo
el mundo se ha hecho alguna herida
pienso que probablemente con la medicina
moderna las personas han podido
clasificar de manera más particular
estos síntomas pero esto no es algo
nuevo existe una inflamación o una
respuesta inflamatoria al ocurrir una
herida
lo que quiero que hagamos en este vídeo
es entender qué causa estos llamémosle
macro síntomas pero qué pasa a nivel
celular porque la respuesta inflamatoria
básicamente es el campo de batalla
inicial de nuestro sistema inmunitario
nuestra primera línea de defensa es la
piel los fluidos en el exterior de
nuestra piel o las membranas mucosas
pero la respuesta inflamatoria es lo que
pasa cuando algo traspasa esas líneas
defensivas
es decir si nos pinchamos con un clavo o
si hay algún tipo de virus o bacteria
traspasa la piel o el moco que rodea las
membranas así que vamos a escribir que
es un campo de batalla inicial así que
vamos a establecer que es una batalla
inmunológica y vamos a ver exactamente
lo que sucede con la respuesta
inflamatoria y vamos a ser muy precisos
la inmunología es un
campo muy estudiado es un área de
investigación activa es decir los
investigadores siguen descubriendo los
mecanismos y es enormemente complejo
estoy seguro que probablemente
estudiaremos esta área durante mucho
tiempo por lo tanto vamos a hacer un
repaso ya que conocemos a los actores
principales y que conocemos en general
quién causa el envejecimiento la
hinchazón el aumento de temperatura y el
dolor así que déjame dibujar primero
algunas células de la piel recuerda esta
es una gran simplificación de todo pero
nos ayudará a darnos cuenta de lo que
está sucediendo aquí tenemos una sección
transversal todas estas son células de
la piel y por lo tanto este de acá es el
mundo exterior justo así
entonces entre las células de la piel
dibujaremos otras células y hablaremos
de lo que hacen aunque no entraremos en
mucho detalle
estas células las llamaremos mastocitos
y vamos a dibujar algunos más tenemos
otro más trocitos y así están si
recuerdan los vídeos sobre la acción
fagocítica o sobre los fagocitos puedes
recordar que existen un tipo de fagocitó
llamado célula dendrítica y ellas
tienden a pasar el rato cerca de tu piel
ellas pasan el rato cerca de las áreas
donde puedan interactuar con el mundo
exterior así que vamos a dibujar un par
de células dendríticas y estas son las
mejores activadoras de las células t
colaboradoras recordemos que aunque se
llaman dendríticas no tienen ninguna
relación con el sistema nervioso se
llaman así porque parecen dendritas pero
realmente son fagocitos y tienden a
estar cerca de donde puedan interactuar
con el exterior para que puedan
fagocitar partículas y así presentarlas
a las células t colaboradoras para que
éstas se activen
y entiendan la alarma de ser necesario
entonces este es un funcionamiento
normal una piel feliz por acá tenemos al
líquido tisular o intersticial que es un
nombre elegante para designar al fluido
que rodea a las células recuerda las
células no están conectadas directamente
al sistema circulatorio el oxígeno pasa
del sistema circulatorio al líquido
tisular y finalmente encuentra su camino
hacia las células así que todo esto está
directamente conectado a los capilares
los capilares juegan un papel importante
en nuestro sistema circulatorio así que
vamos a dibujarlos y en lugar de dibujar
solo tubos dibujaré las células de
nuestro sistema circulatorio así que
digamos que estas son las células
endoteliales es decir las células de
nuestros capilares literalmente estas
son las células que forman las patas
es de nuestros capilares y aunque esto
parece un emparedado recuerda esto
realmente es un tubo sólo que estamos
dibujando una sección transversal y por
supuesto justo aquí es donde tenemos
nuestra sangre fluyendo aquí están
nuestros glóbulos rojos vamos a dibujar
un par de ellos y tal vez fluyen en esta
dirección en este lado tenemos la sangre
oxigenada por acá tenemos las arterias y
del otro lado se transformarán en venas
y los glóbulos rojos perderán su oxígeno
también tendremos circulando dentro de
los capilares a los glóbulos blancos en
mucha menor cantidad que los glóbulos
rojos pero ellos estarán moviendo por tu
sistema circulatorio ya que fueron
bombeados por el corazón
ahora en una situación normal tenemos un
intercambio de gases entre lo que sucede
en tu sistema circulatorio y el líquido
tisular y también existe un intercambio
leve de algunas células y proteínas pero
lo que vamos a ver ahora es lo que pasa
cuando tenemos un intruso
así que vamos a pensar que alguien toma
un clavo lo sumerge en un poco de
estiércol de vaca y te pincha con él es
un clavo grande atiborrados de estiércol
es decir está lleno de muchas cosas
desagradables patógenos probablemente
hay un montón de bacterias que viven en
el estiércol de vaca y bueno no estoy
eligiendo el estiércol de una forma
aleatoria esta es una buena fuente de
bacterias y entonces tan pronto como
perfore la primera línea de defensa tan
pronto como atraviese tu piel suceden
algunas cosas primero un montón de estas
bacterias inmediatamente empiezan a
flotar dentro de tu líquido titular
probablemente mueran algunas de las
células de la piel que fueron perforadas
por el clavo otras van a quedar
lastimadas
las células de la piel que todavía están
en condiciones empezarán a liberar
químicos rápidamente y estos mensajeros
químicos que en un principio se mueven
localmente en el líquido tisular dicen
algo está pasando algo nos ha pasado
estos químicos se llaman quimiocinas
quimiocina es una palabra general para
referirse a las moléculas pequeñas o
proteínas pequeñas que las células
liberan como un tipo de mecanismo de
señalización kim jong de químico y sina
de cinética es decir de movimiento
estos son mensajeros ellos se mueven
entonces se liberan estas quimiocinas y
bueno todo esto es tremendamente
complicado así que sólo estoy dando una
explicación muy general hay muchos tipos
distintos de quimiocinas y además
tenemos estos mastocitos los mastocitos
se activan directamente con el contacto
de
tal vez la punta oxidada del clavo o
puede ser por las quimiocinas liberadas
por algunas de las células de por aquí o
puede ser por algunas de las moléculas
liberadas por la misma bacteria ok
las bacterias también liberan diferentes
compuestos al entrar al cuerpo y
cualquiera de lo anterior puede activar
a los mastocitos y ellos van a liberar
histamina que pondremos en este color ya
podemos apreciar que esto es una
explicación general y aún así es algo
complicado pero creo que ya podemos
tener una idea de qué es lo que pasa y
si la palabra histamina te suena
vagamente familiar puede ser debido a
que has tomado algún antihistamínico en
algún momento probablemente en los
últimos meses de manera especial si has
tenido por ejemplo un resfriado la
histamina es uno de los actores
principales en la respuesta inflamatoria
cuando tienes un resfriado una nariz
congestionada y mucosa y ese tipo de
cosas todos estos síntomas
derivados de la respuesta inflamatoria y
lo que hace un antihistamínico es
intentar bajar esta respuesta
inflamatoria para que algunos de estos
síntomas desaparezcan eso nos genera la
pregunta de si siempre es bueno de tener
una respuesta inflamatoria porque como
vamos a ver en este vídeo esta es la
primera línea defensiva esta es la
primera parte de la batalla de nuestro
sistema inmunitario pero de cualquier
manera una de las cosas que hace la
estamina es ir a las células
endoteliales que recubren los capilares
y hace que se separen unas de las otras
y hace que los capilares crezcan a esto
se le llama vasodilatación así que vamos
a borrar algunas de estas células y
vamos a hacer esta área un poco más
grande vamos a decir que se activaron
con un poco de esta milán entonces estas
células empiezan a alejarse
el capilar empieza a crecer y en la
parte de abajo pasa algo similar y aquí
es donde obtenemos esta hinchazón ya que
de repente al crecer los capilares hay
más fluido pero más adelante tenemos un
área menor por lo que el líquido se
acumula justo aquí a esto se le llama
vasodilatación otra palabra elegante
para decir que tus capilares se dilatan
es decir crecen y por lo tanto el fluido
se acumula allí y se empiezan a acumular
más y más y más glóbulos rojos
obviamente hay mucho líquido y fluido
por acá también hay glóbulos blancos y
también las paredes capilares se vuelven
más porosas de pronto las cosas que no
podrían pasar por esta pared ahora
pueden hacerlo de manera más sencilla y
recuerda todas estas otras cosas están
pasando tenemos estas está minas que han
sido arrojadas a estas células
endoteliales
algunas de ellas entran al suero también
tenemos estas quimiocinas liberadas de
manera local desde el área dañada
tenemos en color verde a las moléculas
que liberan los virus y entonces los
primeros en responder son los fagocitos
en particular los neutrófilos que son
los fagocitos más abundantes y son una
subclase de los glóbulos blancos se
sienten atraídos por estos químicos y
quieren moverse en la dirección donde
hay más de estos químicos así que pueden
pasar por el espacio entre estas células
capilares que se han separado un poco
más entonces digamos que este de aquí es
un neutrófilos empezará a rodar a lo
largo de la pared justo aquí y a esto se
le llama marginación se pega contra la
pared se adhiere a ella y se aprieta a
través de estos huecos en la pared
capilar
a esto se le llama de ap decís o
extravasación algunas veces lo llaman
emigración pero todas estas son palabras
elegantes esencialmente se refieren a
presionarse entre las paredes y después
de esto gracias a la vasodilatación aquí
es donde los neutrófilos llegan y aquí
es exactamente dónde se necesitan
entonces los neutrófilos estarán por acá
y empezarán a hacer lo que hacen van a
fagocitar algunas de estas bacterias se
las empezarán a comer y tal vez también
a algunas de estas células dañadas y
esto es justo lo que queremos que pase
esta es la razón por la cual llamamos a
esto un campo de batalla
al mismo tiempo tus células dentríticas
que son otros fagocitos empezarán a
comerse los virus para después
presentarlos en sus superficies y no
sólo vendrán los neutrófilos ya que como
es un área de congestión y todo el
fluido llega entonces también llegará
células ven y células t que también
experimentarán la marginación se pegarán
en las paredes capilares es decir ya pe
decís o extravasación y después se
activarán y harán el trabajo del sistema
inmunitario específico así que el punto
importante que quiero que veamos es que
la respuesta inflamatoria no es una cosa
simple es de hecho el campo de batalla
donde todos los actores vienen y pelean
incluso la primera línea de defensa de
nuestra piel y después todos los actores
las reacciones no específicas de la
respuesta inflamatoria la cual es
categorizado normalmente como no
especifica ya que esto va a suceder sin
importar lo que llegue aunque claro ya
sabemos que los actores no específicos
son los neutrófilos y también tenemos
actores específicos como las células y
las células tm y también tenemos un
sistema del complemento no específico no
voy a entrar en muchos detalles
pero tenemos a las proteínas que flotan
en el plasma de nuestra sangre que
normalmente están en un estado inactivo
pero cuando hay una respuesta
inflamatoria se activan estas proteínas
y esto no se entiende todavía al 100% ya
que se activan se parten y cada versión
de esta partición de las proteínas es
muy buena para ayudar a matar a algunos
patógenos por ejemplo las bacterias en
este caso y esto en una forma no
específica
este es un sistema complemento que
realmente es solo un conjunto de
proteínas que siempre flotan por allí y
ellas son una buena primera línea de
batalla no específica contra algún tipo
de patógeno invasor así que espero que
esto te dé una buena idea de qué es lo
que sucede en la respuesta inflamatoria
y puedes imaginar que tenemos todo este
líquido por allí toda la sangre se
acumula por acá tenemos algo de líquido
pasando no sólo las células van de los
capilares al líquido tisular también hay
cierto líquido ya esto le vamos a llamar
excitado y entonces todo esto se hincha
se enrojecen y se congestiona y es por
ello que ves estos tipos de síntomas en
un macro el nivel de cualquier manera
espero que esto te sea útil